Here we go. I'm about to start
starting the stream. All right.
Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay,
here we go. Here we go. Here we
go. Um, all right. Hello world.
It's a Raj and welcome to my live stream.
Um,
in this livestream I'm going to
build a machine learning Api, uh,
and it's called a neural
style transfer Api. And why?
Talk about it if I can just show you.
Okay. So here is the base image. Okay.
It's this best laptop for
machine learning image.
And when I feed it into style transfer,
it's going to become this.
Okay?
So it's going to do that.
So what I want to do is just do another
demo and just show you really quickly
how this works. Hi everybody.
It's good to see you.
I have a little chat window
here of everybody here. Hello.
We're all blessings from Norway. Wow. The
Vikings, the vikings are alive and well.
Oh Man, I'm so happy to
see you guys. Uh, I wanted,
I kind of like last minute decided to
do a livestream because, uh, you know,
I set up a live stream studio and uh,
it's time.
So I really want to do these weekly,
right? So, so that, that's the goal. Okay,
so down to business.
So what we've got here is we've got this
little app file and inside of this app
fall, I have my, my thumbnail
videos that I use for youtube.
And so what I want to do is I'm going to,
um,
take that image and I'm
going to send it to my API.
So what I did was I created an API
and so I can send that image there.
So here's the, here's the console.
Let me open up the console.
We got people from all over the
world here in Malaysia, India,
Casa Blanca as a movie, Saudi
Arabia, Canada, Nantucket,
Nan Tuck it. That's what's up right there.
I think that's like a, a jam as well.
Nantucket jam sounds like
it would be though, right?
Like a peach jam. All right,
so let me send this uh,
image test.
I remember I called it test three
or jpeg. I'm sending it to, uh, the,
hold on, it's not called test three
is called test two. Dot. Jpeg.
Uh, who test two. Dot. Jpeg and okay,
hold on. Gimme a second.
Gimme a second here. Uh
Oh no. Yes, I see. It's because it's
not a Jpeg, right? It's gotta be,
it's gotta be be a jpeg right now.
It's an,
it's a PNG de image files.
We got Utah,
Utah. What's up Utah? Okay, so test
three now. Now let's do this again.
Let's do this again. You
Ready? Ready? So remember that,
how to learn mathematics fast
image I just showed you guys now.
Okay, here we go. Here we go.
I thought the data machine
learning is happening in France,
in France on a trained neural style
transfer model is happening as we speak
right now.
And when it is done,
we will see that output.
Okay, so where is that output?
Where is that output? So you saw that,
right? That did not exist before and that
is some machine learning right there.
I took my plain little image and I turned
it into this style transferred image.
Okay, so that's, that's it's
tutorial for today's video. Okay.
So I'm going to show you guys how
to do that in the cloud. Okay.
So you can build this code yourself.
I don't care where you are,
I don't care who you are.
You will build this code and you
will in four command line, uh,
for commands on command line.
You will send this to the cloud
and create an Api just like that,
that you can run in France on.
You could curl the image,
you could send a post request,
you can build a service.
That's how this goes. Okay,
so we're going to start off with this.
Okay.
So also also before I started doing this,
I'm just going to say 10
names just to, you know, done.
Y'All fit tra polar bear at Lewis,
RB Schick, Ali, David and Ben.
Thank you guys for being here.
So let's get started. Okay,
so for people who are watching
this recorded, we wanna,
I wanna I want to satisfy both
the live and my recorded audience.
So we have three steps to do this. The
steps, step one is to build the model,
of course, right? We've got to build
the model and once we build the model,
then we can train the model on Floyd hubs.
I'm going to talk about a service called
Floyd hub. It's not the best service.
Okay?
I just want to say that it's not the best,
but it is the best for beginners just
to get something quick and dirty.
Up and running. Floyd hub
is great. All right. If you
want to start scaling really,
really scaling to, you know,
hundreds of thousands of users,
then you want to move to AWS,
then you want to move to
Google cloud or even a zero.
And I'll have videos on each of those
individual platforms coming out soon,
either next week or the week after that.
Okay?
So the third step is to
serve the model via an API.
So if you're not familiar with neural
style transfer, here's how it goes, right?
You have an image, right? It
could be me, it could be you.
And then you have a source image and
that's the style that you want to transfer
to your base image. And when you do
that, boom you get, you get this filter.
And this paper came out I think
four years ago, four years ago now,
and it was called neural style transfer.
It was by gat teas.
That was the name of the researcher.
And there had been a lot of variations
to that, to that original paper.
But really that original paper
was the, the landmark. It's,
it's the one that started it all.
Okay. We've got someone saying,
make South America great again.
So we got some really hilarious
people in this chat room. Okay.
So you guys are so hilarious by the way.
Uh, I forgot how funny you guys are. Okay.
So how are we going to do this?
Well, it turns out that we,
all we need to do is use one
neural network. Okay? It's,
it's a convolutional neural network.
We're going to build this
thing in python in tensorflow,
and that's all we really need.
So what happens when we
have a convolutional neural
network is what it is,
is it's a series of matrix operations.
It's a series of matrix operations.
We have our input data that is an image.
And an image is just a matrix, right?
It's just numbers,
pixel values between zero and two 55 that
say what color every pixel should be.
And we take that input, um, matrix,
and we continuously apply operations
to it. Multiplication, right?
The dot product.
And in Linear Algebra terms,
we're just multiplying
a matrix by the Matrix,
by the matrices and the weights of the
network over and over and over and over
again. And we might add some
other little tweaks to that,
but it's just a series of operations.
And you might be thinking, well,
that's too hard. I don't understand
that. Well, let me stop you there.
It's not too hard.
First of all,
stop telling yourself that it's
all about your belief that it can.
It's like athletes, right? So if, if you
believe that you can become, you know,
like wolverine level jacked status,
you will do that.
If you believe that you can learn
something, then you will learn it.
You got to believe, right?
So again, I am not a phd,
but do I feel very comfortable with this
stuff enough to go live in front of a
live audience on the Internet with
my name on the line? Yes, I do.
So,
and why is that?
Because I believed that I could
learn it even though I'm not a phd.
And guess what? I did learn it. So,
so take that as an example. Okay. So,
uh, right, so convolutional networks,
they're just a series of matrix operations
apply to input data until we get an
output. And the output is a
prediction, right? And so, right,
this is used for image classification,
but what the researchers have neural style
transfer thought were they, they said,
you know what,
let's use those intermediary layers and
and use those to trans to transfer the
style of one image onto another. Let's
not care about the outputs of the network,
right? So just cut out that, uh, the,
the last part of the network
and just care about what's,
what's happening in the middle right here,
right?
So these colored images are
actually just matrix values.
These are matrix values and they have
numbers and through optimization,
through the learning process,
those neuro,
those numbers become better and better
at classifying the image, right?
Through a training process, which we
don't actually care about right now.
What we care about are these learned
layers because we can use those learned
layers and apply what they've
learned to our image, right?
So that's what we're going to focus on.
We're going to use these layers to
then create our style transfer image.
And so how do, um, how does that work?
So here's how it works. So there are
three parts of this workflow, right?
So we have a content extractor,
we have a style extractor,
and then we have, um, the
combination of both, like,
so we put them together for now
I'm going to talk about math. Okay.
So get ready for this. I'm going to
talk about math in a second. So, uh,
this is the fun part, right? So, uh, so
the first part is the content extractor,
right? So we have our
image and what we want. So,
so there are different ways that
we can think about this problem.
And so what the researchers did was
they said, okay, we have an image.
And that image has some content in it.
That means it has a human, you know,
objects inside of the image. It's
got a sunset, it's got a mountain,
whatever it's got in terms of, um,
objects though. That's the content.
And we want a way to preserve
that content and, and,
and model that content and represent that
content mathematically. So then we can,
we can later, um, utilize, that's right.
So what they did was they used a very
famous convolutional network called BGG
19. This was a convolutional network that
was trained on hundreds of thousands of
images of all sorts of categories from
boats to planes to dogs, whatever.
Okay. So they took this
pretrained network. Okay.
And this is what it looks
like. A convolutional network.
We have a convolution,
which is a matrix operation, a
pooling, a pooling operation,
which is another operation. You
know, I have a great, I don't,
I don't want to repeat
what I've repeated before.
If you want to know how a
convolutional network in general works,
search convolutional network
Saroj on youtube first link.
It's an amazing explanation if I do say
so myself. Uh, but so that's how it works.
But what, what we care about are
these, are these layers. Okay.
So this is actually just one layer, right?
So, but what a convolutional network is,
it's multiple layers. So we
care about this, this layer,
you know a few of these layers
right here and this is pulling. So,
so if we were to visualize,
and by the way guys,
the code is going to be in the get hub,
uh,
in the video description that get
helped code by the way. So if so,
follow along with me here.
So if we were,
if we were to visualize what
these layers have learned,
it's going to look like this, right?
So it's going to be images. I mean,
it's going to be edges and then it's
going to get increasingly more abstract
over time.
So edges will become eyes and eyes
will become faces and faces will become
humans as the layer
the network progresses.
So what they did was they
represented content as this formula.
Get ready now?
Now you got me excited because now
I'm talking about math by the way,
okay?
Okay,
so
[inaudible]
you guys are so funny. Oh my God, you
guys said the most random stuff. Okay,
so content, right? So content,
how did they represent content?
Like what is actually in the
image in terms of objects.
So what they did was they passed both
images through the network, right?
So you have your base image, what you want
to stylize, and then you have the, the,
the style image or the image, the art,
let's just call it artistic image.
And so they pass both through the network.
And so what they did was they found
and they took a particular layer,
let's call it layer to layer two of of
five, but it can be any layer really. Um,
and it took layer two or five and that's,
that's um, that's a matrix of values,
right?
Is it to learn matrix of values.
Okay.
And once we do that, uh, we can then
that's gonna that's gonna give us, um,
a scalar value, okay. That's going
to give us a scalar, a single value.
And what we can do is we can find the
difference between those values, right?
So we pass in one image and
it's going to learn a filter.
It's going to learn a filter for that.
We'll pass it on.
Another image is going to
learn a filter for that.
We can basically subtract those two
filters together and we can get the,
and then we can square that. And we
can do that for all of those, um,
images. We'll sum them
all up and then, uh,
okay,
we're finding their difference
and then we're squaring it. Okay?
So that's how that works.
And that's what the sigma notation meets
for all of those images. Okay. So, um,
we're also multiplying each of
the represent representations
by the value Alpha.
That's right. That's right. The value
Alpha. Um, but we have those two features.
That's what I'm trying to say here.
We have to learn to matrices.
We're finding the difference between
them and that is our content loss. So,
right.
So last functions,
I've got such an amazing loss function
video coming out this weekend.
I cannot wait to show you guys this.
But last functions are all about measuring
how bad our network is that making a
prediction, right? So what we
want is we want a loss function.
That's not going to measure how
bad we are at classifying dogs.
We want a loss function that measures
how bad we are at creating a stylized
image. And so if you think about
it, that's a very abstract, uh,
at first thought like
how good a filter is.
But by and representing it mathematically
this way, we have found a way to
thrives 20, 20, I mean guys, one thing at
a time, right? I got to take over this,
uh, youtube game first and then
we'll talk about that. I'm not,
I'm not saying anything anyway.
You guys are so funny. Oh my God,
I need to like close this chat
window because, um, okay. Anyway, no,
I like it though. I can do both. So,
so that's content, right? We have,
we have the content and now we're,
the next thing we're gonna do is
we're going to strike the style. So,
so content is just, think of
it as a single value, right?
So all of this comes down to a single
value that represents, um, how,
okay,
how,
um,
yeah,
how much content has been
transferred to our base image.
It's like how different our base
images from our content image.
And what we want to do is we
want to minimize that difference.
And when we minimize that difference,
our base image will become more and more
and more like that style image in terms
of content. But content is not
enough. There's also style, right?
So for style,
okay,
for style,
we're going to do the same thing except,
okay.
We don't want, we don't care about
the content. We care about the, uh,
the texture of the image,
right? The colors, the what,
what is where, right? So if we think
about like a filter in general,
there's not really images
that are being overlaid.
They're just like these
textures and colors, right?
So there's this kind of gradient, not,
not in the sense of the math word.
It can be very careful about words
here. But, um, how do they extract the,
well, what one thing to
think would be, well,
let's just directly do the same thing,
right?
So input the style image and find
a difference. Right? Between them.
But what the instead what they did was
they said let's compute what's called a
gram matrix. And what a gram
matrix is. It is, it is the,
it is the transpose of the Matrix,
right?
So a grant matrix is the multiple,
if you take a matrix and you
multiply it by the transposed,
so you flip it of itself,
that's the grand matrix.
And so they took those grand matrices
for both the base image and the style
image, the artistic image, and they
found the difference between them.
So that's what this,
so this calculates the gram matrix then,
uh,
once we do that,
we can find the difference between them
and we multiply by this out by this
value Beta. So there are
two like threshold, not
threshold, but static values.
Here we have Alpha, which
is for the content. We have
Beta, which is for the style,
and we can tweak those to see how
stylized our end result will be.
So that gives us our loss for, for saying
how stylized we want our image to be.
So what we want to do is we
want to combine both of those.
And the way that we combine both of
those is by creating this final equation
here. So we just, we just
add them up. That's it.
We add the content loss and we add the
style loss and that's our total loss
variation loss,
you can call it.
So our loss function consist of other
loss functions and the reason we added it
is because we just want a single,
we want a single end to end optimization
approach where we can just optimize the
entire thing.
We,
we compute the error using
this loss function and then
we use the air to compute
the partial derivative with respect
to the weights of our network. Okay.
And if you want to understand
how backpropagation works,
again search backpropagation Saroj on
youtube and like a million links will pop
up there as well.
Literally anything AI related,
just search the name of what you're
thinking and then the word Saroj and I
promise you it's going to show
up on youtube 98% of the time.
Okay. So all right. So,
and the way they optimize it
was using El bfgs and this,
this is a second order optimization scheme
and I've got a great video on that as
well. Just search second order
optimization by Saroj on Youtube.
And we talk about how instead of
just competing the derivative,
we compute the derivative of the
derivative and in some cases it's called
Newton's method and another in
another case it's called El bfgs. Um,
but it is a gradient based
optimization ski. Okay,
so we're going to build this now
we want to make this into an API.
So let's get to the
code, shall we? So let's,
let's just build a simple model here.
Okay.
So what we first want to do is
we want to import Vgg, right?
So VGG is that convolutional network.
We also want to implement,
we will also want to import tensorflow.
We've got people doing the hundred
days of ml code challenge, by the way.
Amazing stuff.
Hi.
I am so proud of the people of the
wizards who are, who are doing that.
It's just a,
it's just amazing mind blowing.
So VGG is our network.
Tensorflow is our tensorflow,
is my city. No, no. Tensor flow
is our machine learning library.
And then we're going to import,
transform.
We're going to import, transform
to then transform our images as we,
as we do want to modify them a yes,
I know coding train. I love Dan.
We actually collaborated with Dan and
I'll probably will collaborate with Dan
again. He's a great guy and I promoted
him and he's promoted me. And you know,
in a way we're kind of all like the
Kardashians of machine learning shift.
Mid me three blue one brown,
uh, this evening. Uh, Carrie,
Carrie Huang is coming over.
Um,
he doesn't know that I'm
live streaming right now,
but he's coming in a few hours. So I
mean, we all, we're all like, you know,
cross promoting each other.
And you know,
what I really want to do is I want to
make a curriculum that involves all of
them. And you know, we
all have our, you know,
we all have our distribution
channels or youtube channels,
but we're all pushing content
towards the same curriculum.
Can you imagine the anime
cross over level? You know,
if I'm like sitting here
building convolutional network,
Daniel Shiffman comes in and he is
like adding in his like p five dot.
JS javascript stuff for like front
end stuff. You know, Carrie comes in,
he's hilarious.
Uh,
Andrew Trust comes in and he like
explains things so beautifully.
Jabrill's comes in of course, and
he liked, makes a game out of it.
Drills is all is awesome as
well. We collabed as well.
Uh, how cool would that be?
We guys, we need to make this
happen. I mean, it's gonna
happen. So, um, we'll see.
We'll see. So one step
at a time, basically the
Kardashians as, okay. So, uh,
let's, let's get to this before
we run out of time here. So, uh,
from utils import get image.
Okay.
So now what we really want
is a couple of those layers.
So we're going to specify what
those layers are going to be.
So let's just call these
layers by their names,
which they were named by the VGG
authors. Uh, and once we do that
Relu to renew three relu that Oda really,
really relieved by the way his
stance were rectified linear unit,
which is a type of activation function
that diminishes the vanishing gradient
problem we look for.
Okay.
So we've got four layers here that we're
going to begin to think about when it
comes to style. And then when it comes
to content, we just have one layer.
We're going to call relu four two.
Okay.
And so now that we have that,
let's,
let's now say,
let's optimize.
So in the optimize function here,
we want to perform optimization.
Okay?
So what I'm gonna do is going to say
inside of our TF graphs,
so we want,
we want to initialize our graph and we
wants to take VGG an existing network and
extract those features from it,
right? So, so how do we do that?
How do we actually extract features from,
from Vgg in?
So I'm going to show you how we do that.
Um,
as default.
If that device is going to be our device,
right?
How's device?
Yes, Youtube is my main job. It is my
main job. That's the way I like it.
Okay. Uh, okay. So with that,
we're going to compute
this style image first. Um,
and that's going to be TF dot placeholder.
So we want a place holder for that
style image, right? So the initial,
let me make this bigger. Let me
make this bigger, bigger, bigger,
bigger is always better.
Not Always, not always.
Okay. Style image is going to be,
we're going to use a place holder.
So what the placeholder is in the,
in,
in the Tantra flow computation graph
is it is the gateway into the network,
right?
So this is where data flows in.
And so that's why we're creating a place
holder here because we want a way to
input the style image,
right?
So we're gonna do that for the style
image and we want to do that for the, uh,
the base image. Okay? So our placeholder
is going to be of tight float 32.
It's a very simple image. We have a
predefined shape that we want to give it.
My sound and image are not in sync.
Okay? Well that we got to fix that.
Really? Okay. Hold on.
Let me go check that out. Really,
my sound and image are not in
sync. Seriously. Oh my God. See,
this is what happens when a life stream
alone. I'm like trying to set up this, uh,
this whole thing. Okay. Uh, okay.
So what I want to do actually is just,
okay,
so next time I'm going
to be better about this,
but let's find that since it's
syncing for you. Right. Great.
Let's look at this code. So let me
just show you this code guys. Okay.
So we have our style image. Okay. So,
and then we have our base image here.
We have our network vgg.net we feed
both in as parameters that gives us our
network. Okay. So once we have that,
we take those layers and we compute the
gram matrices of each of those layers.
Okay.
We compute the gram matrices of each
of those using them and then using the
matrix multiply featured,
right?
Remember the gram matrix is the transpose
of a matrix multiplied by itself,
which is exactly what this line is.
This is the grand matrix.
We are feeding all of those.
Um,
okay.
We are feeding and I'll wrap at the end.
By the way, do not leave and I will wrap.
If you leave, you don't get to hear the
rap, I'll probably make a fool of myself.
But that's just how it goes,
right? Whatever it takes, right?
Ai Solve Ai or die trying.
So Graham Matrix,
we're storing all of those inside
of this array style features, okay?
So that that was us computing the style,
a loss in the form of Graham matress cs
for all of those layers that we defined
beforehand, right? So that was that.
And so once we do that,
then then and only then we can say,
okay, inside of our TF graph,
let's compute the content preacher.
So we already did this for style and now
we're doing the same thing for content.
So we already defined a content layer,
right?
And remember there was no Graham
Matrix involved in the content.
So you don't see that here we are directly
pulling the learn to value for the
content just like this.
Whereas for the gram matrix,
we had to compute that, right?
Using TF or NP numb Pi's
Matrix multiply function.
And so once we do that,
then we can combine both of them.
So this right here is
just, um, this is like a,
this is like, uh, an exception check,
right? If it's, if it's slow, then, uh,
set the image back to what it was before
because it's taking too long so we can
ignore that part. So, um,
now for our content loss,
we already found, uh, the,
the value from that specific layer.
And this is us computing it by
multiplying it by the weight.
And so if you look at this, you're
thinking, wait a second. Uh,
yeah.
What you're thinking like,
wait a second,
where is that? Where is
that? [inaudible] right?
So here it is. This is, this is
exactly what we're doing. See?
So this equation is what we
are looking at right here.
Okay.
Where is it? Where is it? It is,
it is the difference
between both of those, uh,
features divided by the size of the
content and multiplied by the weight.
And that gives us the content loss.
Okay.
So now that we have all
of those style layers,
yeah.
Now that we have those layers, we can, uh,
compute the style was,
so we had the style layer values and now
we're competing the style lost values
until it comes out to this. So what
is happening here? Let's talk about,
we have our, the size, the height by
the width, by the number of filters.
So it's a three dimensional tensor size.
We have our features.
So what we're doing is we're reshaping
what we just computed. Uh, no,
not this one.
This is for each of the layers.
So these are the features for the layers.
We have our grand major season,
that's our style.
Grand matrices.
We append to the law says the difference
between those grand matrices and that
gives us our style losses.
And lastly, we use that.
We use that value multiplied by the way,
and that is our style loss.
Now the word variation here
just means, uh, this total loss.
So I said the total variation loss.
And so in order to compute
the total variation loss,
we add both the style loss
and the content lost together.
And that's going to give
us our total loss. Okay.
So this right here is this
preprocessing step. That's not,
it's not really necessary, but they
went ahead and did it anyway. Um,
it's just kind of a, it's a nice
to have. It's, it's a Gotcha.
That's the thing about a
lot of this research code. I
mean, this is research code.
Like it's Kinda, it's Kinda messy.
It's, you know, it's, it's not good.
One of the most impactful
things you can do, by the way,
if you're interested in Ai, which I
love you if you are, which you are.
So I love you. If you're
watching this, uh,
one of the most impactful things you can
do is creating clean, well documented,
readable code. All right? For the ml
community as, as a whole, right? This is,
this is what beginners
need better code. And, um,
carrots would be a great wrapper for this
and there is a karass wrapper for this.
Um, but, um, right? And so this
is the training loop, train,
train, train, et cetera. Okay.
So now let's get to the part that I've
been talking about the API part, right? So
how did I do this?
So if you look at what I've done here,
if you look at what I've done here,
I have made an API using Floyd hubs.
So let's,
let's talk about Floyd huff for a second.
Okay.
So Floyd hub is not the best.
Okay?
Oh my God, it's Lloyd.
All right. Fully hobbies,
not necessarily the best
GPU, um, provider on the web.
But I'll tell you what it is, is it's
really easy for beginners to get started.
Okay? So I've got a couple of jobs
here that I've been running. Um,
and so when it comes down to it for
Floyd hub, you literally can say,
here is my, here is my, uh, repository.
So I've got a repository here and right?
So let me open this. Here's my repository.
Let me, let me look at this. And Sublime.
Sublime, okay. Evaluate,
okay,
you've got to have this.
So in this Floyd requirements that txt,
you just add all of your dependencies,
just like list them,
and it's going to install all of
dependencies in your virtual environment,
in the cloud for you. So this is
gonna be tentraflow can we care?
Os It'd be whatever you want and it will
install that for you and your virtual
environment.
So what you can do is once you,
once you find your repository, you can
run the command Floyd in it, right?
So Floyd and knit fast style transfer.
And what that does is it initializes a
new project in your current directory and
then you can serve, well, first of
all, you can even train that model.
So this is a pre trained model
that we can serve directly from our
hold on,
old on.
We can run that directly from our
command line like that. And so what this
is now doing is it's taking our code,
it's,
yeah,
putting it on the web. And so, oh,
I've reached your Max number of jobs.
I've been running a lot of jobs on
this thing. And so once we do that,
then we can simply,
I got some people,
okay.
So then we can simply just run a simple
API call using this line of code just
like this, and then it's going
to return back, whatever that,
whatever that output images like I just
like I showed you before. Okay. Um,
that is super simple.
And if we go to the,
the code that I have for you in the
get hub description, if we go to that,
check it out. Amazing instructions
for you. Here's how to train it.
Yeah.
Or here's how to train on Floyd hub one
line of code and you're training your
model on this, a cloud service. Here's
how to evaluate it, right? You trained it,
okay, here's, here's, here's
how you rent in France. Okay.
You can do the same thing for video.
And really this applies to any kind of
model. And how do you even do this? Well,
you got to make a Floyd hub account,
right? Let me do this with you. Okay,
let's do this together.
Let's make a [inaudible] hub
account sign up for free. Um,
okay.
It's raw. It's raw edge, okay.
No credit cards need to care.
And no, they didn't sponsor this.
They did not sponsor this video. I just
personally like it. Okay. Just like that.
And so I dunno how it's already, oh,
it's already got projects for me,
so we can just look at those if we
wanted to. And so inside of this work,
it's even got the instructions,
like how do we do well,
we just initialize it here.
And so once we initialize it locally,
we can add some code here and then we
can run it on a Gpu. So Floyd, Ron Gpu,
and then it's gonna run
on a GPU in the cloud.
So I want to say, and so once we do
that, we can serve it as well from,
from that API. We can, we can create an
API around this. So you might be thinking,
well, w w there must be machine
learning APIs out there.
So clarify as one example,
right? So clarify does have, um,
does have some models that are trained
for you pre trained in the cloud and
they're pretty good, but they're doing way
too much, right? So someone can clearly,
uh, pick one of these and do them really
well. He's the, one of the newer models,
I'm talking about generative adversarial
networks. I'm talking about, um,
I'm talking about variational
auto encoders. Um, you know,
one of the more advanced
models that you know,
people don't know about so much and you
know, clarify as a great example of a,
of a,
of a group of people who create a really
sustainable business around just Ai.
So think about it, just having one single
API call as a service, you can do that.
You can make so much money, you can
make so much money doing that. And um,
you know, just just yesterday
I had a farmer in Belgium who,
who emailed me a picture of his crop
and he was asking if I can help him with
classifying.
That's right.
So there's just so much potential
out there to create really impactful
businesses for the world.
Uh, clarifies one example.
I just want to show you that
really quickly. Okay. So, uh,
that's it for this live stream.
Let me answer some questions at the,
at the end and I'm going to wrap.
So guys,
go ahead and ask them questions and
then once you do that, uh, I will.
Okay.
I will, I will end this live stream
after our answer your questions. Okay.
So while I look for an instrumental
to play rap instrumental,
any questions guys?
What are the questions here? How to
become confident with large code bases?
Great question.
So the best thing to do is to contact
the author of the code base, right?
So they are the architect and they
know what parts are best for beginners.
So don't just try to dive in
yourself, contact the author, um,
look at the documentation.
Ideally, ideally it's got
documentation, but if not,
contact the author and uh, they
will help you. They will guide you.
Don't just try to do it yourself. I mean
you can, but uh, it would take longer.
So you want to go the
fastest way to do this. Um,
what bit are you thinking of making
next? Um, I want videos on GPU,
s specifically GPU providers.
Should I go for AI or ml?
Which one before? Guys, AI is the
biggest bubble machine. One again,
is inside and deepening its inside,
but she wanted, gives a subset of Ai.
Do you think Java's triple
over Tech Python soon in ml?
I don't think it's going to overtake it,
but I think it will catch up for sure.
It is catching up.
Is machine learning very impro if very
important. Of course it is my niece.
Thank you. And two more
questions. Two more questions.
Is Floyd costly when you said
train and test? Um, yes. So,
so that's why I'm saying it's
only for beginners, right?
Because once you want to start scaling,
Dan's going to get expensive. And,
and I think when it comes to scaling,
you want them the cheapest solution
that is also the most dependable.
And for that I would choose either AWS
cloud or Azure. But to start off with,
you know, there's, there's a very
small learning curve for Floyd hub.
That's why you should start with that.
Um,
okay.
How does start with deep learning? Uh,
watch my intro to deep learning, sir.
Playlist on Youtube. Juris law. Um,
it's because that's my signature.
And a William, last question. What ceiling
would you recommend for tensorflow?
I would recommend python.
Okay.
So now I'm going to rap about some
topics where someone just say a topic,
one word go
Friday everybody. It's Friday.
How it kind of a hard beat.
Here we go.
All right,
so I'm about to wrap NASA a freestyle.
Someone's going to say a topic right now.
Here we go. Where's the, where's
the, where's the topic guys?
Where's the topics?
I think these guys are a Gnn
that's not really like a topic.
Awesome.
Okay.
Hey Yo, are we some Isaac
Asimov? Don't try to look at me.
Don't try to Piss me off.
I try to read Psi by him.
My books in mom movies in my
looks try to dress that way.
I got hair is so wavy. Okay. I level up.
I leveled down NLP man.
I'm rapping like a cloud.
You guys are laughing in the chat but
it's okay cause I got big coin any way.
It's all good. Hey, hey.
Hey. All right. Oh Wow.
Actually I sleep with her.
Alright guys,
so thanks for tuning
in to this live stream.
I've got more livestreams coming
up for you. I love you guys.
Thank you for watching. I've got so much
AI machine learning content coming up.
So if you haven't subscribed, hit
the subscribe button and, um, yeah.
Thanks guys
for watching.
Okay.